it's key to find a community and
anything big you do be part of the scene
for your industry follow and hopefully
one day also be followed by the right
influencers or competitors in your
industry be active in relevant online
groups and contribute to them when you
can these people are your support for
improving and promoting your app in
terms of your image framing yourself as
a thought leader in the industry is a
wonderful idea you'll need to share your
thoughts if you want people to trust you
as a thought leader consider running
your own blog and sharing your knowledge
this process is not just about promoting
a product left and round it's also about
becoming a trusted experts for example
if your product is a bike disk your blog
can cover things beyond just the bike
topics like cycling is a sport either
outdoor or indoor this tells your
followers that you know what you're
talking about when it comes to cycling
you can write about fitness in general
or healthy habits to show that I can
trust you to give me lifestyle advice
including just being active at my own
desk consider publishing ongoing pieces
of content to highlight your
professionalism in the industry and
promote your online visibility this will
help both your SEO and your social
presence some of the most useful groups
I would say are groups that are really
really targeted to you so I'm part of
this five-person group of people who are
in the share economy like budding
entrepreneurs in the share economy and
then you can really have the
conversation you want to have right so
so those have worked better for me than
just online forums or these big
communities I want you to take a few
minutes to explore online groups that
you'd like to be active in start
thinking about what it means to really
become a thought leader in the field and
think about your plan to get there when
you're ready right to blog titles that
you'd like to write in the blanks below
after you come up with your titles go to
the forums and outline what these blog
posts will cover and then you'll have an
opportunity to get feedback from some of
your peers in the course